more than 10 000 people in Israel have
been marching towards West Jerusalem
from Tel Aviv the protests against the
government's proposed judicial changes
are now entering their 29th week MPS are
due to vote on Monday on a bill
restricting the Supreme Court's powers
to strike down government decisions but
during a televised address earlier this
week prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
warned he would go ahead with parts of
the judicial changes
Oren Civ is journalist and commentator
at plus 972 magazine or when you're
joining us from Tel Aviv you were with
the protesters I believe earlier today
have you seen anything like this before
in terms of mobilization sizes of crowds
as well
thank you for having me we've seen in
the last six months math protests across
Israel in Tel Aviv Haifa West Jerusalem
and other cities in sizes we haven't
seen before but this March this
mobilization to Jerusalem to West
Jerusalem is is a historical a moment on
Tuesday there was another strike day day
of protest against Netanyahu and its
governments and the changes they are
planning and at the end of this day in
the evening 20 or 30 activists the
leaders of this protest movement from
different groups started to March
independently to Jerusalem and today is
the fourth date and every day more and
more people are joining them
spontaneously they're marching on the
highway sleeping in a camping sites on
the side they've asked people to bring
them food and water and supply and I've
seen hundreds of car passing by and
helping them and more and more Israelis
are joining and what we are hearing from
these people I spoke today is the fear
to lose what they see as the Israeli
democracy they fear if Netanyahu goes on
with their first bill on Monday
afternoon
the Israel they know will no Lord be and
exist they are not getting impressed by
the promises to change a bit the laws
let me jump in here because this is the
part that I want to make very clear and
we need to have a conversation about the
substance of the law now because
protesters for weeks and weeks were
protesting the judicial overhaul the
package of many many measures that would
have according to critics weakened the
Supreme Court and the Judiciary
um relative to the government but what
is go what is being
voted on on Monday and which passed in
the first reading last Monday or the
Monday prior uh is actually only a small
slice relatively speaking of this of
these judicial changes talk to us about
that and what it is at stake for
Monday's vote
so
Netanyahu Penn is the extreme Coalition
wanted to pass
all this set of builds together to
change completely uh the way the system
operates and specifically affecting
Jewish Israelis and the life they were
used to till now in Israel on Monday and
following uh the math protests including
Civil Disobedience we've seen on March
Netanyahu froze those bills and went to
some kind of negotiation
and now he's just trying to pass what
they call the probability a law which
will prevent from the Supreme Court to
cancel or to change a policy set by
ministers or by the government but what
we are hearing from the protesters on
the ground they say it doesn't matter if
it's one bill or 10 or 10 bills or
anything we will not let Netanyahu do
any change because they know and he said
it and his Coalition Partners said it
before they're doing it slowly because
they understood that if they do it in
one go the the protest and the
resistance in Israel and abroad from the
U.S will be too strong so they're trying
to pass it bit by bit we've seen
Minister itamar benvear saying this is
just the first course and we will
continue
so so this is interesting then the
protesters you're telling us whether
it's the whole judicial overhaul package
or whether it is just one small isolated
slice of it the protesters are coming
out on Force no matter what
exactly they see it as their land last
chance to prevent these bills and other
bills to pass they're marching to the
parliament in their statement today they
mentioned square and the protest in
Ukraine in 2005 is saying we can Siege
the parliament gather around it and
they're calling people not to come for
one hour or two but to come for days and
days so it's unclear if they will state
their sentence only till Monday till
this specific bill will pass in
Parliament or they're going to stay for
weeks all right well we're going to be
watching this very closely they're now
into their 29th week of protests
orenziev thank you so much for joining
us on the program today
thank you so much